what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I learned like I learned a
gaming term apparently it's called like
being tilted which basically means like
you're mad because you're because you're
losing if that's the case I used to make
people tilt in Call of Duty all the time
back in the day I was like man don't be
mad at me for reckon you'd be mad at
yourself for being so bad but anyway Oh
so we are continuing on with our story
on Earth X yes I love Earth X it's one
of my favorite stories I love this story
again this is like a dystopian future so
it's just like man like like things are
really poppin off now so far what we
basically had is the idea that like
everybody on earth has powers I mean we
didn't know exactly how it was they all
got powers but like everybody on earth
has powers ah the result is that there
really is no more need for superheroes
but things turn out exactly like we
would expect the world's completely gone
to pot not only that in Los Angeles
California you had this skull which is
basically just a kid that had the
ability to like dominate the minds of
others but the result is that because
the skulls army is basically growing a
number to the tens of thousands and he's
making his way across the country
basically looking to completely and
totally take over the United States and
then the world Captain America has
basically been traveling around trying
to rally as many people to his side as
he can now of course from here we pick
up an England with Captain Britain this
is kind of cool because Captain Britain
as he's shown here it's basically just
the guy who's running Britain at this
point in time he just got the guy who's
basically running the ship we're not
really told exactly how this happened
but like we can surmise we can kind of
take a guess and most likely what
happened was that like America in
England when all these different people
across the country gained their powers
big government basically just fell to
pieces
in Captain Britain rose up now the funny
thing about this is that when it comes
to Brian Braddock is one of those
characters that people just sort of make
fun of right like oh man Captain Britain
he's gonna save the day not that's kind
of how people it's kind of how people
you know talk about Captain Britain he's
kind of a joke about laughable character
that no one really pays much attention
to but if you go back and read his
stories while he is kind of a joke of a
character the way he's written sometimes
he's God at work counts but the whole
idea is that with Captain America
showing up here and saying look like we
need you to our side what we find out is
that what basically passes for Excalibur
and earth acts that they're all
basically gone like they're they're
basically out of this now what ended up
taking place here is the group one
against a guy named grey gargoyle who I
want to say is paul duvall i think
that's his name
i want to say with his powers he can
touch things and turn them to stone I
can't remember honestly he's so obscure
of a character and I'm too lazy to look
him up but regardless all the members of
Excalibur are stuck in stone but
basically that's why Captain Britain's
like the only person here Captain
Britain says no I'm not gonna join your
wife's like go do your own thing but I'm
my loyalty is to Britain my loyalty is
not to United States I will do whatever
I need to do in order to keep this place
protected and so from here we pick up
with the skull in New York in the home
of Norman Osborn now the funny thing
about this is that this throws in
destruct relief the nature of the
President of the United States right
like take away the armies take away the
Secret Service what's the president of
United States just a guy in an office
and that's it like the president exists
and functions because people are willing
to do what he asks them to do but that's
it I mean Norman Osborn is just like a
guy who's here but like when there's no
one there to protect him well then
suddenly the president becomes awfully
vulnerable and that's what goes on here
like the skull walks in and it just like
Judas a guy in an office man like you
have no power like you you are just a
person who's here and like all the
people who could help you I've taken
control of and like they all belong to
me so like you're gonna die now like
we're gonna kill you and that's what
happens here like he essentially turns
the mind of Norman Osborn inside out and
forces Norman Osborn to like confront
gwen stacy now again this ties in to the
whole history of spider-man in the fact
that the main Marvel Universe continuity
of spider-man is still a part of Earth X
in a sense that Peter Parker was in a
relationship with Gwen Stacy she died at
the hands of Norman Osborn and he's just
kind of forced to face this illusion of
her being there but of course the mask
is basically ripped off but of course
again in this scenario is actually the
skull himself who looks like Gwen Stacy
but the mask of Norman Osborn is torn
off and that's when we find out it's Ben
Green Goblin the entire time so again
it's kind of what we expected for the
most part I mean Norman Osborn a Green
Goblin go hand in hand and and there's
there's rarely ever been a circumstance
where Marvel has given us Norman Osborn
and then not brought in Green Goblin
somewhere along the line but at this
point we pick up with really with
Machine Man meeting with Reed Richards
now again in the last video we talked
about how Machine Man was created for
the purpose of being a super soldier
more or less but he had essentially
developed human attributes and the
result was that somewhere along the line
The Watcher had basically snatched him
off of Earth and brought him to the moon
now the idea was that the watcher is
blinded we don't know who
did the watcher we just know the
watchers blonde and the result is that
machine man started you know spill or at
least starts rolling all this
information to read richards all the
things that he's learned and one of the
things that he's learned here is that
when it comes to like all these beings
on earth who have superpowers that we're
basically antibodies or at least these
these superheroes and all these people
with powers are essentially antibodies
for the earth they're designed to fight
off quote-unquote infection that
infection basically being whatever space
invading organism or race or Thanos or
what-have-you
comes to earth and tries to destroy it
they're basically designed to be a
safeguard but we don't know why all we
know is like that's the case the
implication is that it's because the
Celestials wanted it to be that way but
again we don't know if everybody having
powers was part of the plan or if
everybody having powers was the plan
gone awry so again it is kind of
intriguing but it's designed to kind of
build up this whole idea of like the
greater role that Earth X plays with
regards to this story but at this point
we pick back up with the Inhumans and
again the Inhumans are not really our
guides on this really our guide it's
more of a machine man but the Inhumans
are here to provide us with a kind of
objective perspective which is to say
they've basically shown up they've come
back to earth after everybody has powers
and they're basically figuring things
out as we figure things out is the
reader which is one of the reasons why I
like the Inhumans as they exist in this
story the issue with this is that Carnac
who doesn't really have any powers per
se specializes and like figuring out how
things work basically it's kind of a
caveat that Marvel uses to give him
powers even though doesn't really have
powers it's just the thing that he can
do the karnak has been trying to figure
out what's been going on here in terms
of why everybody has powers the initial
indication was that everybody getting
powers everybody being in a human was
the result of the actions of Maximus the
Mac the brother of blackball who had
somehow detonated this terrigen bomb and
gave everybody inhuman powers on earth
the indication was that it wasn't
actually Maximus who did it because
Maximus was defeated by Black Bolt
before it could be done so the question
was asked like who who set this whole
terrigenesis thing in motion
and so what Carnac starts to sort of
question Medusa to a degree Mesa can say
hey look maybe it wasn't really Maximus
the mad maybe it was you know somebody
that guy over there who doesn't talk
maybe it was him you know where he kind
of hints at that idea
Medusa dismisses it now remember Medusa
as the wife of Black Bolt
is loyal to her husband and loyal to the
king Medusa will kill every inhuman egg
that exists out there before she will
betray her husband willingly and that
leads us
to the revelation of who detonated the
Terrigen bomb and we end up finding out
it was actually blackboard himself that
black vault had detonated this terrigen
bomb and gave everybody on earth and
human powers and the reason for this is
because of the fact in the mind of Black
Bolt that there were there were some
Inhumans who had left the royal family
and there were some Inhumans who by
whatever manner and whatever means had
developed their powers and the result
was that Black Bolt
saw how they were treated in a lot of
ways people believe they were mutants
because no one knew about the Inhumans
and someone Black Bolt looked and
realized that some of them are actually
Inhumans and that normal human beings
are treating them terribly because they
have fantastic powers Black Belts idea
was that if the Inhumans are going to
leave earth he's going to provide
quote-unquote one last gift he's going
to detonate this terrigen bomb and all
the Inhumans that exists on earth are
going to gain powers and that's exactly
what happened everybody basically
started gaining powers and that's what
ends up happening with with regards to
machine man explaining all these things
to Reed Richards when we jump back
machine man basically says like this was
part of the plan when the Celestials
modify the genes of early man and they
created the deviants and the Eternals
and the baseline humans would eventually
go on to develop mutant powers or what
have you and went be Inhumans arrived on
earth and so on and so forth all that
was part of the role of these Celestials
that this is what the Celestials do the
Celestials travel from one world to the
next and they plant their their
offspring their seed so to speak inside
of a planet and then they charge the
denizens of that planet to keep it safe
not really telling them what it is
instead they just modify their genes so
that there are various superheroes that
exist they'll fight among amongst one
another but they will be protective of
their home and so following the desire
for survival if an alien race shows up
like Santos invades or something like
that they'll fight off Thanos because
he's a villain he wants to destroy the
earth they want to keep the earth safe
all the while not realizing what they're
actually doing it's protecting this
celestial seed inside of the earth and
that's what's happening right now at
this point what seems to be going on is
the Celestials are making their return
because the seed has germinated and now
it's just a matter of the celestial
inside the earth being born and what it
does when that happens the entirety of
the earth will be destroyed and so at
this point we jump directly to the
Battle of New York basically with the
skulls army are facing off against
Captain America's forces and this is
interesting this is one of the one of
the reasons why the skull is such an
intriguing character because this guy is
basically just a kid and he views the
world as a kid
well I want respect treat me with
respect if you don't treat me with
respect then I'm just gonna be angry at
you like he's very much childlike in
terms of how he views the world and the
result is that we're one of the one of
his members basically insults him ah
then he presumably says you guys do what
I tell you to you guys don't have
freedom here you guys do whatever it is
that I tell you to do you guys live and
breathe because I allow you to and he
illustrates this point by taking away
everybody's ability to move and so you
have Captain America's forces running
through just killing every single person
that they come across neo destroying all
these different forces of the skull and
then ultimately going for the skull
himself now ultimately we end up finding
out that like the forces of Captain
Britain ended up joining the forces of
Captain America and they're literally
just going through and wrecking as many
people as they can now ultimately the
skull simply says okay fine everybody
get back to it because honestly what
keenum Oh am I gonna have if I can't
dominate this place at the same time
what you also have is the Incredible
Hulk in this situation now remember this
fight being as cool as it is brings in
some pretty unique things The Incredible
Hulk is an extension of Bruce Banner not
very much in a literal sense Bruce
Banner is basically the soul of The
Incredible Hulk and so in this instance
the skull can't really dominate the
incredible Hulk's mind because there's
not really a mind there to dominate the
Hulk does what Bruce Banner wants it to
because it's like Bruce Banner tearing
off an arm and the arm doing whatever it
is the Bruce Banner wants to do that's
how this works and so because of this
where the skull tries to dominate the
Hulk right off the bat it ultimately
doesn't work but when it's up happening
is the forces of the skull managed to
get a hold of Bruce Banner and when they
do they basically control the Incredible
Hulk as long as he dominates Banner he
dominates the Hulk and so what's
basically happening is the 4tl really
the skull himself is just slowly and
steadily taking over all the forces of
Captain America the school continues to
sort of torment Captain America again
like making him see all these things
making him do all these things the
things that he doesn't want to do ending
the war so on and so forth it is kind of
intriguing and so that's when we find
out that again because of the fact that
Black Bolt had detonated the chair Jim
bomb what he had also done is he tried
wanted to cover his tracks leaving earth
and basically saying like we've done
into this bomb no one can know what
we've done we've timed the detonation of
this bond so that when Reed Richards
activates his device that he will
believe that he basically sent all this
in motion that somehow energy from
vibranium in order to give the world you
know infinite energy that somehow it
gave everybody powers we can just kind
of walk away and let them believe that
The Watcher would have seen everything
that had happened and The Watcher would
have known everything that had happened
and The Watcher would have told Reed
Richards he would have told the earth
superheroes and so the result was that
black bolt had taken the eyes of the
watcher he basically blinded him so
again this if you guys look at this
story for what it is for these little
moments here and there there are a lot
of stories it's spun out of Marvel
Comics that we learned about this whole
thing for example the idea of a Terrigen
bomb being detonated and everybody
getting powers from from terrigenesis
on earth that was used in the events of
the aftermath of infinity and though the
whole idea of inhuman The Watcher being
blinded that's original sent all these
stories that Marvel has recently
launched have all been predicated on
this there are a lot of cool things that
go on here but what we end up finding
out is that the idea of Black Bolt is to
try to destroy the Celestials now the
voice he has is capable of doing that
the voice can like shatter a god this is
one of those things where Marvel kind of
beefs up the power of Black Bolt for the
purpose of this story in the main Marvel
Universe black bolts nowhere near this
powerful but if you read house of him
it's definitely powerful enough he
whispers and wipes out what amounts to
like two or three football fields worth
of land I mean it's a crazy set of
events Black Bolt flies out to meet the
Celestials on the blue area of the moon
in an effort to try to destroy them and
hopefully find some way to be able to
save the earth but without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain it make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]